with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller
howdy guys I am Von Miller and this is
the Von cast and we are live in the BR
app this is episode two of my guy Josh
Allen I'm saying you can leave comments
below and we'll answer your comments
throughout I like to start the show by
answering or looking at some tweets
um throughout this uh this last past
week and the very first tweet that we
have is comeback season this was the
first time in franchise history that the
bills won a game that they never LED
until the last play of Regulation this
is also the biggest comeback of your
career too it was a it was a tough game
like how did you feel about it did you
of course of course we felt like we was
going to win the game but like being in
real time like how did you feel like
about that again well 17 points going
down 23 you know the start that we had
kind of the interception and the first
drive giving them a short field
um but down 23 right before half going
down there and getting points was huge
for us
um and obviously defense bowed up you
guys did a heck of a job getting this
ball back a couple times I mean that
pick that player had an End Zone on I
know but that was I didn't realize how
long that their Drive was I mean it was
like an eight nine minute drive like
it's crazy and they ended up with no
points from that that's that's huge
um and then the pick instead of being on
the three yard line if it's incomplete
pass
right we're backed up situations just
trying to get one first down for the
field now we get the ball to 20. now we
got a chance to go down there and score
and win so
um but again I thought guys were pretty
composed on the sideline
um you know Diggs likes to get animated
I don't know if you've been around him
when he's been animated yet on the
sideline
he I tried to keep him at Bay he got a
little pumped up uh but for the most
part I mean you said all the time don't
blink and I don't think guys blinked uh
we just kind of stayed the course and
figured it out yeah I mean we always
talk about don't blink and for me being
year 12 like
you know games are always going to be
games and well I feel like where I'm at
in my career I like to look for the fun
and I look I like to look for the
enjoyment in all these games whether we
win or lose which we're gonna always win
these games but for me to be in the rain
like in Baltimore in a crazy environment
I've been in games like that before we
played the San Diego Chargers uh this is
when I was in San Diego we played the
San Diego Chargers on Monday Night
Football in 2012. we went in to have
21-0 like in front of the whole nation
second half we came out now Peyton
throws a touchdown we get a pick six
paint throws another touchdown we kicked
the field goal and it was done and that
kind of felt like the same type Vibe and
I always like to look for the fun in the
games even last week when we lost to the
Dolphins like it was a fun game and even
though we lost like we went down to we
went down to the [ __ ] wire playing in
this game like and it just felt like
last week it felt like I don't know we
don't like to look back but for me it
felt like you you watch your little
brother like fight an older kid or you
watch your son like fight over the kid
and even though he lost like you're
looking at him like bro he's a he is a
dog like he's gonna be he's gonna be
great one day and that's how I felt
about this team you know it's only been
here for like six months and to see like
us fight the way we did last game and
this game like it really hit home for me
that's where you build like the love for
your teammates that's where you really
like that's really like Forge that Bond
like with your brothers going through
games like that and you don't want to go
through a whole season like untested or
untried even though we lost last week I
said it was good medicine this win is
good medicine too it just shows it's
like no matter no matter what situation
that we're in like we always have a
chance to win the game whether we're
positive or whatever it may be like you
always have to go through the fire to
like Forge the team that we really have
man and so being in that game it was fun
you know I always knew he was going to
win but even if it went the other way
like I like to look for like the Silver
Lining and situations like that and bro
it was fun man and you know whenever we
win we have fun we made the plane do
backflips on the way home we have like a
fun we have a fun team and I really
appreciate being on this team this next
this next uh tweet is my outfit
um it's my outfit before the game do you
have any like outfits that you do you
get ready to do you like how do you go
about like your swag before game well I
got no swag so I might need some help
you got a swag bro I need some help in
your department I I wear a nice pair of
Jordans every once in a while but I I
wear my travel suit for the most part I
try to you know think business
and it's just one less thing for me to
think about it was like all right I'm
wearing my travel suit don't have to
worry about it don't just stress about
looking good for a picture but I know
this uh I saw the the Tweet the Beyonce
sent it to you and I understand that you
had to wear this
um
yeah you were walking so we were on the
bus and you were going you were walking
actually down from the family section
after the game and some of the guys were
just staring at you like he looks like a
freaking astronaut they were like
it's crazy like they Beyonce Adidas they
they sent it to me Ivy Park like I had a
whole nother outfit I was gonna go with
but I got this on I think Thursday in
the mail and I opened it up and it was a
like a silver bag and it had like a
little crossbody bag attached to it and
I started going through the bag and it
had like the hoodie and like the
sweatpants and then they had the the uh
the Boost to match you pulled it off
dude and I was like bro I'm like bro I'm
worth it and I even if it wasn't like
from Beyonce like I was still like wear
it because I feel like pre-game outfits
post game outfits that's just part of
like sports you want to like look fresh
you want to like not stand out in a way
like like look at me but I'm gonna wear
cool [ __ ] like this yeah that's just how
it is and I feel like the meaning behind
it like it being like Beyonce and like
Ivy Park like around Marathi [ __ ] and we
got a whole team full of swagsters we
have a yeah we really do this to Saran
like to everybody even even the big guys
like the Quan Roger saffold Roger
Safford and Jordan Phillips like
Lumberjack Mitch yeah I know yeah Mitch
Morris like you know everybody likes to
dress up you know this is like uh if we
were like rappers and entertainers like
this would be our concert and you want
to like look good like for the show so
it was from Beyonce I would have wore it
even if it wasn't from I need some help
though like it's going forward I'm gonna
need some some fashion advice we keep
winning games like bro you can't wear
whatever you want to wear like I was
with Peyton suit every single time like
no matter if it was preseason where we
can run a travel suit like suit every
single time and they only had like three
suits too it was like the orange he
always liked to be color coded with the
team so when he was with the Colts it
was like a blue with like a gray
pinstripe and with the Broncos it was
like a blue with like an orange
pinstripe with like tan shorts and I'm
sure if we do the research like Peyton
Manning has the same outfit like every
other he's probably still wearing it too
on the Manning cast he still wears it so
you know you don't you don't need any
help bro we keep winning games bro
you're gonna create your own swag this
uh this next tweet is
is the tweet from Lamar Jackson which I
got a lot like I got a lot of respect
for Lamar Jackson I think like I said
before like year 12 you just started to
like see like the silver lining in games
um Lamar Jackson is a great player
you're a great player whenever they give
you like props like this man after the
game like it's super cool we're gonna
see these guys again it's not gonna be
the first time that we play it's not one
of those games where you just like of
course we're gonna celebrate and we're
gonna hang out this is what you do the
football guys do not like when you don't
celebrate after games especially big
games like this it's hard to win this
league yeah we beat we beat the
Baltimore Ravens and you just got to
take it in but you got to know like in
the back of your mind like we're gonna
play these guys again and it's super
hard to beat teams twice so this this
was a good tweet from Lamar Jackson you
know to give us our props and I think
you said like after the game like it's
it's one of the many battles that we're
gonna have yeah and again like he's
as an opposing quarterback it's so
frustrating to watch him on the field
because it's third and 15. it doesn't
matter like he could first and 10 turn
15 basically the same thing you know
like
making plays with his feet I mean there
was a couple times he was sacked in the
backfield but then he wasn't you know
and he's finding a way to get out and
he's out running everybody but some of
his throws he made the other day too
were unbelievable some second window
throws I mean around Tremaine only where
his guy can get it
um the dude's a baller and there's only
a few really few guys in the league like
that it doesn't matter what down or
distance it is like they've always got a
chance and he's one of those guys and
um you know I said this last week and I
know you've said it like he's up next
for that contractor he's going to be the
guy he's going to be the highest paid
guy and that's kind of how how the leak
Works
um but he's he's bitting on himself
right now and
I mean it's he's playing playing
fantastic football and
um Above All Else Like You can tell how
teammates respond to a guy yeah right
I'm saying they are rally around him you
know he just has this unique ability to
make his teammates around him play
better than what they normally would be
and I know he has a team full of Ballers
but he just all the great leaders like
you like you know all other great
quarterbacks Lamar they just have this
snack to
rise up like have their teammates rise
up to a level that they wouldn't
normally play and I know I said
something about his contract too like
you want guys to get paid like you want
guys to be the highest paid ever because
they just lift the floor for everybody
else and then you'll be back up again
and you got to get another one right
here so you know I always been an
advocate of guys getting paid like and
especially like a girl a guy like Lamar
Jackson he's done everything under the
sun that you could possibly do to put
himself in great position for a next
contract and he even took it a step
further you know betting on himself and
the price is is only going up it's it's
only going up and everybody around the
league should want him to get paid
because once he get paid he gets paid
then it rises it helps rise the pass
versus contracts you got you got Michael
Parsons and all these guys coming up and
it rises up the the wide receivers
contract and the offensive line and then
everybody that has to go against these
guys so I'm always a big advocate for
guys getting paid and we got we got B
Henderson 91 said we got a flat card we
got a flat tire and Harrison was at
Pennsylvania on the way to Buffalo to
the Baltimore game and we ubered the
rest of their way and still made it
that's love that's crazy and that just
shows you like Bill's Mafia like they go
all the way out for their fans man they
they go all the way out for their team
um I've been I've been a part of you
know two other great fan bases from you
know Ram's house the ramali to Broncos
country and everything that they do
there and you know it's not a knock on
anybody else just bills Mafia is just
it's just different man this is all we
have here is it's football man and it
definitely feels great to be a part of
this this next uh tweet
we of course this went viral
we got we got dorsey's middle guy and
you know I start first like you know you
after the game you see stuff like this
and you don't you see the plays and
stuff in the game
and I saw this clip and I saw Dorsey
going crazy like and for me like it felt
good that somebody carried just as much
as I did to win this game and to see him
like just go ballistic bro it just shows
you like nobody loves losing you know
and I've been on teams before like you
know coaches they just get in this
autopilot where we win or we lose they
just stay the same and you know to see
dorsey's expectation for us to win every
single game and him to put his all into
each and every game and like react like
that bro as a defensive guy like I loved
it bro as the quarterback how did you
feel about that I know I thought the
same way like I I got on the bus after
the game and honestly like offense we
played 93 plays that game and 110
degrees that's what it felt like on the
field and humidity like guys were tired
or sore were beat up and I get on the
bus and he goes
do you see the video I'm like no
pulls out shows it to me I'm like oh my
God he's like ah the Motions got the
best and I'm like one I'm kind of upset
that they they showed that on air like
you kind of want to protect like you're
putting these cameras like yeah you want
to protect you want to you want to show
the good you don't want to show the bad
like but again that's what people people
want to see but to actually have really
motion and and to be fired up about that
like guys feel that they're like we know
that he busts his tail game playing all
week like he works extremely hard his
call sheet is pristine like the way that
he the amount of effort
that he puts into his call sheet like I
know it sounds simple but as an
offensive coordinator like that's that's
your toolbox right there like it is it
is a very clean looking and he's got a
lot of help whether it's you know Rob
Boris skip Joe like guys that are in his
ear helping him out Shoals
um
he takes a lot of pride in it man like
when you when you lose you should be
frustrated like I said that and this is
kind of a quote that's been around for a
long time like you showed me a a guy
that's okay with losing I'll show you a
loser you know like
um but yeah guys appreciate it we love
it and uh it fuels you to be better yeah
I appreciate it bro it wouldn't matter
to me like if he reacted like that you
know every single time bro like I would
love it bro I really don't see I really
don't see a problem with it and I've
been in the league a long time and I've
never I'm sure coaches have done that
before but I just we just never see it
and it just it just feels good to know
that somebody like cares just as much as
the players do
um Bill's Mafia Bill's fans they've
donated more than a thousand donations
to to us charity since he suffered a
concussion in the Bengals game on
Thursday night and this is just another
Testament to Bill's Mafia and I'm sure
they did this before they did this with
uh Andy Dalton's you know charity after
Lamar's a couple years ago with me and
the Patricia Allen Frontier or I mean it
I'm still speechless kind of about my
situation and what it's kind of turned
into and it's something that's near and
dear to my heart now that I'm gonna be
able to you know help raise money for
really for the rest of my life and you
know my grandmother's now memorialized
there they got the Patricia Allen Wing
um and we got the the fun there and the
foundation that again finding new ways
rather it's like auctioning stuff off my
cause for cleats golf tournaments in the
future like the team 17 membership that
we're we're starting to do there like
it's just so cool and Bill's Mafia again
they they set the standard really like
they they understand that we play this
game of football and these
we're human at the end of the day
um but for them to go do that too you
know they've done it for Andy they're
different lar but now like a division
rival like
we're supposed to hate each other right
like that's what they want yeah that's
that's what people want to see but again
just going against the grain and doing
something and making something that's
that's bad and turning it into good and
I think those Mafia is the best example
of that you know two is going to be out
this week versus the Jets and I think
you know I think it's good I think it
should take as much time as he as he as
he can to you know get back to 100 you
don't want to rush into these things you
know football is just a dangerous sport
you know and they uh that's why people
love it you know we try to make it as
safe as possible but at the end of the
day it is a dangerous sport and they're
humans out there and even though like we
go against these guys like they're our
brothers at the end of the day you know
they're our colleagues and you know I I
sit and I pray before each and every
game you know to protect um you know all
of my my teammates my opponents and our
and our family of friends from uh any
major hurt harm or danger and that goes
to everybody man you never want to see
you know um to go out you never want to
see anybody you know have the type of
injury that they had so even though he's
not playing you know I feel like he
should take as much you know time as
possible
um to you know get back to 100 it's all
about players safety and at the end of
the day like we're humans like we really
are and I know when we out there we look
like you know tough guys and this and
that like you kind of we look like
robots or whatever it may be out there
like just bashing against each other but
underneath the helmet and underneath the
shoulder pads and all this stuff like
we're humans and we have a mom and a dad
and brothers and sisters and kids and
you always want to go back and make it
home back to your family and friends for
sure
Josh actually brought me here
um you know in free agency when free
agency started you know my agent first
day was pretty slow I was in the Bahamas
chilling and um you know I'm asleep I
got the phone like right next to me and
this is the whole day so that tells you
like we had a lot of fun in the Bahamas
but um sleep during the day and I had
like my phone next to me and it never
rang and then my my agent called me the
night before and he was like hey you
know the Buffalo Bills they might be
interested and I was like cool because I
always thought like I was going back to
Los Angeles Rams like I just wanted to
hear everybody else's you know spill
like this is the first time in my whole
career my whole 12-year career where I
get like recruited by other guys and my
agent told me like the business is going
like reach out and the next morning said
they gave Josh Allen my number he was
going to call me and um you know Josh
called me he FaceTime me and it was
crazy because I had reached out to these
guys like three years before like not
like you know I was I was just trying to
see like you know how Buffalo everything
even listen to me like what's up with
Buffalo like question mark
yeah it was pretty cool like again I'm
like new in this league two two years in
I get a message from Von Miller like
like this is freaking cool I was kind of
StarStruck I'm not gonna lie I was like
bro how's Buffalo like how is it man you
know I was I miss his PO and Tremaine
and you know Tre Davis and all these
guys I was just asking them like you
know how I was but Josh called me you
know went on FaceTime and he was like
hey man you know you get here bro like
gave me the whole Spiel and I was like
man this is cool man because nobody else
everybody takes me you know of course my
brother's from the Rams like they text
me and they reached out to me but to
like have somebody else from another
team like reach out to me just you know
when you're getting recruited like it
feels cool to like get that handwritten
that handwritten note or like get that
FaceTime and you know I talked to Josh
Allen and Diggs on the phone like they
both called me and it was super cool bro
like to get like a message from these
guys I'm sitting in Bahamas and it's
something it's on my Vlog on YouTube but
I'm sitting here on FaceTime talking to
Josh Allen in the Bahamas on the beach
man it was super cool what it what it
being like what was his Spiel to you to
like get in touch with me yeah man he's
just just like hey like here's his
number if you want to call
that'd be great
um obviously try to try to convince you
and drag you away from Los Angeles to
Buffalo which is no easy task you know
but I just at the end of the day like
understanding where we're at as a
football team and what we need to do to
take that next step I was just like I'm
I'm all in like I'll do whatever it
takes
um so yeah I was at the golf course I
was actually with Matt Barkley and I was
FaceTiming I'm pretty sure I facetimed
like three or four times yeah
it was cool right we had talked a few
times and I was like I mean was like was
like what's up I'm like relax like I
just got off the phone with him I said
he's gonna call me in a little bit
um and I think you got on a plane I went
to call you and like went straight to
voicemail and he being calm was like I'm
not I can't get it through this guy did
he block me did he do this and like I
don't know what's going on we'll figure
it out when it happens if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it doesn't we'll
we'll figure it out
um but yeah that was uh that was an
interesting day I worked my tail off you
know being big still it was good man I I
felt like I felt like family bro I
didn't feel like you know it was just a
Spiel to get me here like and I'm a fan
of football too I felt like I belonged
here and when I agreed to the deal right
and I told bean I told other guys that I
wanted to like I wanted to announce it
myself right so I agreed to it in like
30 minutes passed by to be honest I was
still like trying to process it in like
my mind like LA to Buffalo like I could
go Rush with like Aaron Donald for the
rest of my career don't it don't even
matter about wins or losses like I could
just rush with Aaron Donald and Leonard
and Leonard Floyd and and Greg Gaines
and we're gonna have like a crazy pass
rush for the rest of career like and I
just kept like going back and forth and
I had agreed to the deal and being had
called me and he was like Hey so uh
what's up hey like what's up are you
gonna announce it that's like yeah I'm
gonna do it I'm just you know I'm just
you know taking my time with it and Josh
had called me too and he was like hey uh
what you gonna do like like all right
let's get it done and I'll lie you're
right man I need to stop I need to stop
procrastinating man and I have posted on
my Instagram I was like Bill's Mafia was
good it's 40 open and like the rest is
history and I just had to turn off my
phone too because I was still talking to
like coach McVeigh and like Odell and
like Aaron Donald and all those guys and
you know it was just so hard for me to
like as you can imagine it's a big
decision yeah bro it was just because I
respect all of those guys bro it was
just so hard for me to say like hey I'm
going man like and even the next day
when I came I was still going back and
forth I know everybody's heard about
those stories but you know the rest is
history you know we're here um you get
to know some of these guys you get to be
around coach McDermott coach McDermott
I've been a fan of football so I I know
he's a defensive minded Coach and he's
typically been like a tough guy like you
know like a hard coach and when I got
here it just seems like you just have
such you just have such an effect on not
only coach McDermott but this whole team
like you just have like this this happy
like the moment is never too big whether
it's big or not like you just have this
this easy going like personality about
you and whether it's the Lunch Ladies or
like the janitors or like the training
staff with like Nate and tabani like
everybody's so loose and I think that is
a testament to you you like that in
college and high school too I've been
like that really for as long as like I
can remember and again like I have so
much joy in playing this game like I get
to go to work and do what I've wanted to
do for my entire life and be an NFL
quarterback so like I get I'm pumped up
like every day I wake up like I I get to
do my dream job and like I'm gonna have
fun with it like I get to be in a locker
room full of dudes that are you know the
perspective best at what they do they
work extremely hard you work extremely
hard player might like everybody in our
building like has this mindset and this
goal of you know going together and
trying to get this goal done and like
that's it's inspiring to me and like to
know that like I get to be the
quarterback here and like again play for
such a an excited fan base in Bill's
Mafia like
it's not like this everywhere else and
like I count my blessings every day to
have the relationship that I have with
Brandon Bean and the relationship that I
have with Sean McDermott and Ken Dorsey
and like the coaching staff and the
training staff that I've had here
there's been so much consistency
that it's not like that everywhere no
it's not like I know guys that have had
different quarterback coaches different
coordinators and head coaches every
single year that they've been in the
league and to know that I've been
basically with the same staff now going
into my fifth year
there hasn't been much turnover like to
to be able to develop and build those
relationships I think that's a huge part
of it is just keeping the same guys and
the front office and really you know the
pagulas trusting who that they've hired
that they are the right people for the
job and it might have taken some time to
get there but
um you know the the culture and you know
where we're trying to trying to go in my
opinion is in the right spot yeah I mean
we're in the right spot and I'm sure you
know we we lost four straight Super
Bowls and it's like a lot of expectation
we want to go out there and win and I'm
sure each and every time that you go out
there like it's a lot of emotions that
that you feel like you just have to get
yourself up for each and every game to
go out there and play at a level that
you're playing at it you have to put you
have to go to a certain place before
every game and you like you throw up
before every game and it's crazy because
for some reason like I always hear it or
I'm always around it like I'm just I'm
in the mirror like putting in my towel
like looking at myself trying to get my
game face on and I just hit up and I
just said and like I don't even have to
like look around and like see who it is
like I just know I just know it's Josh
and the way that I like positive
self-talk to myself is okay like and
everybody like they throwing up before
the game but I am ready for this like
I'm gonna go out here and I'm gonna win
this [ __ ] by myself like I got him like
I got everybody that's just the positive
self-talk that I have with myself like
to throw before everything because I
used to do it like when I was young I
used to throw before every game but like
no it's like you're like you're 33 and I
always like to do as much as I possibly
can
to really have peace and I know we
talked about this um we talked about
this with with the bills but I'd like to
just have peace before every game and I
put myself in a in a mindset where like
no matter what happens even though I'm
expecting to win even though I'm
expecting to go out there and do
something crazy like I'm at peace
whatever happens but to throw up before
every game like that's just what you
have to do before your game to get you
in the right mindset dude like I it's
it's not like a an anxiety like I don't
feel it anywhere else I just get this
weird like gaggy sensation I know it
sounds weird and like I'm a creature of
habit like I'm I'm slightly
superstitious I might not be
superstitious but I'm a little stitches
um that's a quote from the office but
I just every like there's just a trigger
as soon as we get done with our pregame
I run inside I put my helmet by by my
locker room it's just like all right I
gotta I gotta get something up and going
back to even in um at Wyoming college
like I I didn't throw up before games
and like throughout the game I would I
would gag I would dry heave and like I
would throw a ball on my felt like there
was just some weird things that would
happen with my body that I just didn't
feel right
going to my rookie year is either rookie
year second year we were at Detroit
Lions for the preseason game and like I
finally I just like you know what I'm
just gonna try it I threw up in that
game I was like I didn't have any of
those symptoms like it was just like the
weirdest thing so I was like you know
what like I'm just gonna have to start
doing this from now on and
um you know I've got I've got some guys
that usually throw up in in the room
with me sometimes they're there
sometimes they're not everybody exactly
yeah
uh it's like 21 Jump Street right where
they're like everybody going yeah
um no I don't know like it's just it
doesn't make me feel any yeah like I
don't know it just it's something that I
do and I think it's I try to convince
myself that's like a primal yeah it's
like something Primal like you know
hungry Warrior is gonna fight harder so
like it's my body telling me like all
right get this up so you can go out
there and fight harder so that's the way
I try to phrase it my mind whether
that's true or false who the hell knows
uh but that's what I do right like I
used to throw up a favorite game but
mine was just like bro it wouldn't it's
a little anxiety not like I was afraid
to like go out there and places like bro
I want to go out there I want to go out
there and I want to do something special
each and every game the record for sex
for every game like the record for sex
in a single game was set by Derrick
Thomas he had seven sacks in the game
and whenever I'm going out she's been
close no the most I've had was three and
so Derek Thomas he actually missed the
eighth second the game and the guy threw
a
touchdown
and they won the game it was versus
Seattle Seahawks in in Kansas City so
like I used to have like devolved
because I want to go out there and I
want to do something crazy like before
each and every game so it just like when
I used to throw up it just used to put
me in the right mindset so I can I can
honestly feel you know I can honestly
feel you on throwing up a fairy game and
speaking of speaking of greatness
the Yankees Aaron judge just hit number
62 so as we speak Man Records is getting
broken right now man shout out to you
know to Aaron judge man I've been a fan
of him for a very long time like super
did you play baseball I did play
baseball up in up until my last year of
high school I almost played Junior
College
um but ended up transferring out
mid-year to Wyoming so that's crazy man
shout out to Aaron judge man you know
I've been around a lot of great
quarterbacks I've been around a lot
greatness you know my whole career I've
been blessed you know I've been around
Peyton Manning
um I've been around Matthew Stafford and
I I would even say like Tim Tebow
because even though that we didn't have
like the success in the postseason like
everybody would you know imagine
like we you know I got to play with Tim
Tebow he's just a natural born leader
you know he's a winner and it just kind
of rubbed off on me and the rest of the
locker room
um we got another question is like if
if I could add one former teammate to
this build team who would I add I mean
come on everybody you know everybody
knows that question man I would add my
God Odell man and I know we're like we
got we got receivers I know we got
receivers I know we got some of the best
receivers in the game it's just the type
of guy that he is and the type of energy
that he brings to the locker room like
it's it's it's Odell Beckham like I've
been knowing a guy for eight years now
and you know from his his point of view
about stuff like you know I don't really
feel like that about like a lot of
people but like I get his point of view
like I get his point of view I just feel
like in a different lifetime like we was
like brothers at some point like you
know we grew up together like not like
as young kids but in the league like
we've grew up and had success and had
failures and had to overcome it so if I
could add anybody to this team which we
never know it might it might happen you
know I love to play GM sometimes like
Julie noted you know I love to play gym
I know we FaceTime Odell like early in
before the season even started like
Odell is just such a great guy you know
he visiting the Giants and doing all
this stuff but you know I think he's
gonna I think I think at the end of it
you know we will see Odell in a great
place
um I've been around a lot of great
quarterbacks
um I've been around greatness
and the energy that Josh really brings
to this team like I really enjoy it man
like I know it's year 12 and like but I
come to work like each and every day and
it's fun like you guys make it fun from
you and the d-line and you know the
receivers and our coaching staff like to
have Coach Washington coach Frazier
coach McDermott like everybody's so
centered around winning and you'll be
surprised like even though you go out
each and every week to win like it's
only a few teams that really put
everything into winning each and every
year each and every game so it's been
great man and I got the winning set off
the football field too like I play golf
with with Josh and Jordan poyer Jordan
Poirier is like my designated golf buddy
you know whenever I'm going I could just
text Jordan and he'll he'll like pull up
and he'll come golf with us like I got
to golf with you guys at Craig burn and
some of the success that these guys are
having like I saw it on the golf course
you know I saw guys like put it together
and you know string together some pars
and you really get to know guys like off
the football field you really get to
know guys like outside of our element
you know you get to see it the way they
react to success you get to see the way
they react to failure and being on a
golf course with these guys man it was
super cool how long you been playing
golf really since I mean a little bit in
college like my dad would take me when I
was a kid every every once in a while
but it wasn't like going to the range
and having range sessions and
um but you know the house that I got
here in Buffalo now it's uh it's very
well equipped for golf and trying to
make my game better and I've seen my
game already increase I got a simulator
in the basement now and uh nice little
outdoor yeah
his house like I see my I see myself in
Josh like when it comes to like our team
and our teammates I designed like my
whole basement around like my teammates
with the Denver Broncos like pot roast
he was 360 pounds and sometimes we would
go out like he would he would like be
hesitant to like sit in chairs so when I
designed like my basement every chair
and every piece of furniture in my
basement is it's gonna hold up to 450
pounds or more like I've designed my
whole basement in Denver before I like
sold it I designed it around my
teammates from the bar to like the game
games and when I went over your house
and I saw like the part three and the
golf simulator like it reminded me of my
basement bro like it's super cool I know
you got the the F1 simulator coming like
and all this cool stuff man it's cool to
to like to like see like the things that
I did earlier on my career and you guys
were super cool it is it is kind of a
surreal position though like when you're
able to do that too and like have
teammates over and like again we're in
Buffalo like there's there's not a whole
lot going on like in terms of off the
field like what what's cool about our
locker room is guys want to hang out
with each other like last week I Monday
it was Monday Night Football I texted
the guys like three or four o'clock I
was like hey I'll order pizza and wings
come over if you want to come and like
just let me know and also he was like
yes yes yes I was like I gotta order I
gotta order some more food now so but
like at the drop of the Hat guys are
just like yeah we we want to hang out we
want to have a good time we want to you
know build that that camaraderie off the
field and I I I'm a firm believer in
that I've been a firm believer in that
for a long time that that pays dividends
on the field it does it does and you
always you just ask yourself like what
do championship teams do like we all can
answer that question like they hang out
they get to know each other they care
about each other they spend time they
truly care about each other we gotta we
got a question from Joseph stopa
and he asks what is your favorite golf
course and why well here in Buffalo we
got a lot of amazing golf courses and I
really like playing at Craig burn it's
it's a it's a tough course it's a
championship course you know I have a
lot of water hazards a lot of a lot of
grass a lot of grass around like the
golf course it is it is a tough course
what is your favorite course to play in
yeah I mean again crap like crack room
is like the first golf membership I've
ever had so like it's got a special
place near there my heart but I've this
last year was a really good year for
golf in terms of places I got to play I
got to play uh Augusta National which
was freaking awesome I got to play
Cyprus Pebble Beach
um spyglass
um Shadow Creek like some really really
good courses
um but I think if I had to choose one I
think I'm going with Cyprus and I got to
play
um with my dad and actually Jim Nance
who's calling our game this week and
um yeah he's from there he lives he
lives here he lives on yeah he lives in
or he's got a place at Pebble and
um yeah he was very gracious to take us
out and it it was just it's it's a
special place man it's it's uh it's like
spiritually because when you walk it
like it's it's six like the three like
every six hole like those six holes are
different like the first six are kind of
like kind of woodsy then the second six
are kind of dunes and the last six are
like right by the water and it's got two
of the coolest par threes back to back
that you'll ever play
like it's it's special it's a special
place Savannah's cool man I I like going
to golf with like all my buddies and I
like hanging out too man and really my
very first time hanging out with Josh
like he invited me over man we're
hanging out gambling a little bit and we
started playing Blu-ray and all of a
sudden like I'm the one getting booed
for everything like in my mind I'm
thinking like I think like dang like are
you is this a prank like are they doing
this on purpose like is everybody is
everybody just cheating no no is
everybody cheating me because they want
to see how you're not you're not doing
this you're not doing this to the
viewers right now
we've got seven other guys that would
attest to you probably booed 30 times
and we only booed you twice right
because again it was always my fault for
some reason it was all like it would
always be like Von Miller's first time
coming over like all right we'll let it
slide like heat it up walking away he's
taking a couple hundred bucks from
everybody you know he's he's the big
winner of the night and I got I got
booed the most but I ended up you know
leaving with the most so it was all good
but I really thought like it was a point
in time world like okay this is
initiation like they're just trying to
see how I react they just trying to see
like what type of guy I am I'm gonna
keep it cool man you know I'm gonna
chill crazy part we were taking it easy
on you too he said they're taking it
easy on me Blu-ray is just one of those
games where like you just you know
friendships they'll come into question
like you got to play with like yo boys
like your real boys or you know a lot of
stuff when they come into question
um you know Josh like I said it before
like he reminds me like of Will Ferrell
like you know this he doesn't take
anything serious and if this was a if
this was a movie it would be the
football version of Talladega Nights who
like play we know like you would be Will
Ferrell who would be myself
go Jamie Foxx Jamie Foxx because he is
funny he is funny we got Stefan Diggs
and Isaiah McKenzie Isaiah McKenzie's
Kevin Hart Kevin Hartford show hey
little guy
um Stefan Diggs I don't know the actor's
name but from the boys a train have you
seen the boys I have on Amazon
and Devin Singletary
Dawson Knox would be
if if we can get Seth Brogan to lose
some weight
which we can get him
um and then Devin Singletary
hmm
uh
the guy from tenant
Denzel son yeah yeah yeah Denzel son for
sure we got Jordan poyer in case I know
I know like Troy Aikman is not like a
actor or anything but I would have like
a young people right there that's that
show him I don't know where I'm looking
at but that's Stefan Diggs a train from
the boys I would have I've always told
him that too like last year he still
hadn't paid up I said if I can get you
three touchdown game for Halloween you
dress up as a train he's got to he's got
two this year I would say like you know
of course Troy Aikman he's not an actor
but Case Keenum he just reminds me of
like treyman ever since he came to the
Broncos like he reminds me Ryan Gosling
would play case Ryan Gosling I like that
I like that for sure and even talking
about the Broncos like we got some what
ifs here all right we got someone else
and I always like to play GM and in 2018
we had the chance to draft Josh Allen of
course we took Bradley chubbing I love
Bradley Chubb like that is my brother
and if we were took Josh I would have
never been able to build that
relationship with Bradley Chubb but what
if
Josh Allen came to the Denver Broncos in
2018. it would have been crazy bro
coming from Wyoming coming to Denver
yeah
um
you and me both would have been first
year bills this year
it was crazy bro for sure man and the
crazy thing is in 2011
I was supposed to get drafted to the
Buffalo Bills at three but the Broncos
ended up taking me like the night before
like the night before the draft like all
through all through like you know
off-season training and like draft prep
and all that stuff like agents telling
me you're going to three you're going
three to Buffalo Bills three to Buffalo
Bills and then the night before I was
actually at a dinner for uh President
Obama and they like one of one of my
agents he told me he's like hey the
Broncos are like super interested I
think like good name drop too he said I
think like they gonna take you I think
they're gonna take you number two and
like the draft came and like I still
wasn't sure like it because in my heart
like I always felt like I was the best
player in the draft of course like they
took the Carolina Panthers they took Cam
Newton number one so I was still like
dang like where I'm gonna go and then
like boom I get this call from from John
Fox and and Dennis Allen and you know I
ended up going to the Denver Broncos and
you know I guess we'll never know
because we're here on the same team and
we got a lot of high aspirations this
year so it is it is super good
um you know I'm gonna move to Stefan Dix
because they got Stefan Diggs on the
show next next week
I Love Stefan like been a fan of Stefan
before I even got here you and Stefan
like to be honest like if y'all went
here like it would really be no reason
like
for me to come here like you guys came
here you guys are like Superstars and
like I knew like if y'all could be
comfortable here and if y'all loved it
like I could love it too man so what is
what is Stefan Diggs meant to your
development
I mean he's meant he's meant a lot and
just in terms of you talked about on the
field play like having a guy that you
can rely on to go up and go get open
catch the ball but mentally you know on
and off the field mindset wise like
and it's been really cool though to like
see his growth as a not just as a player
but as a person too since he got here
you know having the whole media
reputation of you know he's this Diva
that didn't didn't want to be in
Minnesota and force his way out and he's
going to hate it here in Buffalo and man
he's
like he's just he's grown he's grown so
much and it's been so cool to see his
progression and again I think he's the
best receiver in the game I'm so
fortunate you know to play with a with a
guy of his caliber and we get along so
well we joke around with each other
um you talk about being a brother with
Bradley like that's that's my brother
right there and you know just being able
to be comfortable and him be himself me
be myself around each other and again I
think everybody in the locker room kind
of feels that way where you can you can
be yourself and make coach McDermott
does a great job like he wants you to be
you he wants you to wear your emotions
on your sleeve he wants you to be
yourself and let your personality out so
um yeah he's been a lot and I freaking
love the guy you know I'll go in here
and I I say it
um you know Stefan Diggs is the best
receiver in the game
um Josh Allen is the best quarterback in
the game and they are the best duo in
the game but your opinion like what are
top what are the other top five you know
you had to say five but what are some of
the other Duos quarterback wide receiver
Duos that you like think are like top
five or up there yeah I'm gonna trick
question and go Pat Mahomes and Travis
Kelsey I I consider him he's uh he's a
he's a receiver you know
um the way that they're on the same page
all the time it's it's awesome
um I would go
so the top five
am I on there or do I exclude no we're
not gonna talk
we got Joe and Jamar Chase Joe burrow
and Jamar Chase I think Matthew Stafford
and Cooper cup
um are up there so that's three
ah let's see who else would be up there
probably Tom and Mike Evans of course
[Music]
um
help me out here I'd like I like you
know I know it's still early but I like
Jalen hurts and I'm like AJ Brown like
you know those guys that's a pretty good
dude you know I like I like those guys
like oh no man you know the eagles they
going crazy like a lot of respect to
those guys man
um you and you and Diggs best duo in the
league you gotta have like a cool
handshake like how did this handshake
come about we've had I mean five or six
different handshakes over the course
like it's it's been Ever Changing ever
evolving it's like one day it's like all
right you know what we're gonna add this
it's like all right it's as soon as we
do that it's like added forever and we
have to remember it so
um I have a handshake basically with all
of my guys like
all receivers all running backs
all alignment
um so like pre-game get like when we do
our our team for two or three plays that
we do before we go in the in the locker
room make sure that I could do every
every handshake you know I do Dion and I
do Roger and Mitch and then I go baits
and then spins and then Dawson and then
Gabe Isaiah staff in the motor and then
like it's just you got to have it with
everybody and it's just something that's
little they're not all super uh
extravagant
um but there's some there's some fun
ones in there that uh you know that'll
I'll do forever with those guys you know
and speaking about forever like dig said
he wants to grow old with Josh like what
does that look like for you I don't know
man and that's a when he said that it
made me feel a little uncomfortable I'm
not gonna lie no I freaking I love I
love him man like again you talk about
just a guy that
he's changed my life and I feel like
I've changed his life
um so to be able to have a guy and feel
like you're kind of in the same position
as somebody be able to lean on him and
him lean on you
um you know it's it's been special and
again he's here for Long Haul I'm here
for the Long Haul you're here for the
Long Haul like being able to again
continue to develop that that
relationship and
um you know we're we're on a we're on a
good level right now like it's it's body
language it's eye contact it's like all
right I I look at him I know what he's
going to do you know if I call a certain
route and he gives me a look like I know
what he's going to do and to be ahead of
the Curve
like that like it's just that's it's
hard for it's hard to stop you know like
to be on the same page with somebody and
know exactly what he's gonna do before
he does it
um it's definitely a a positive it's
it's a positive man and a special man
I've been around for for 12 years man
and it's an honor and a privilege to be
here it's an honor the privilege to be
your teammate you know I'm gonna end I
always like to end with the top five and
I just want to ask you like Josh Allen
like Mr MVP I call it you don't have to
say it Mr MVP what defense is what top
what are your top five defenses or
players in those top five defenses that
give you the most problems or the most
trouble I mean I'm gonna
I'll take the easy way out for the first
answer and go our defense and training
camp again the guys that we have are
pretty special and you know hopefully
we'll get Trey white out there back soon
because he's a special player you talk
about Jordan Micah yourself
Matt and Tremaine like guys that are
just
again that have grown in this system and
know it like the back of their hand man
it's been it's been awesome to see you
guys work and continue to get better
each and every week even even when we
lose guys like it's just guys step in do
their job and Frazier's been doing a
great job with you guys and putting you
guys in positions to be successful
that's been awesome but in terms of like
just guys out there man like again Aaron
Donald like making sure that you've got
two on them at all times four four hands
like you have to have four hands on them
and sometimes that's that's not even
sometimes it's not enough yeah
um he's up there
um I thought you know Joey Bosa when I
played him a couple years ago he was
pretty dominant yeah Joey and Nick both
of those guys both of them yeah crazy I
don't I don't think I've played naked we
played the Niners but I don't think he
was he was on the field at that time
um
miles Garrett's another one just a
physical freak he's an actor
go Aggies
um just a freaking nature man they can
they can change the game
um
trying to think here there's there's
been some some specials I think
you know obviously
who we're going up against this week
um TJ watt probably is not going but guy
inside cam Hayward I think he's one of
the more underappreciated defensive
lineman in the league that's my draft
class he's he's he's got all the tools
to freaking change a game too and he's
he's gotten to me a couple times he's
hit me a couple times and forced a
couple picks
um he's a special player he really is so
that's something on on our Radars this
week we got to be aware of and uh
you know I think in the back end even
I'm gonna go this week as well might
Minka Fitzpatrick who's you know uh he's
my draft class yeah he's one of the best
still young but again like the the ways
that he can change a game and he's a
ball Hawk and he's he's really never
where he's supposed to be in terms of
like what I'm seeing like if I'm
thinking like it's post high like I
should know where he's at yeah but he's
not it's like all right I don't I don't
know what covers are doing because he's
just kind of going real like they kind
of give him that that leeway to just
jump routes and and use his instincts
and again he's he's rarely ever wrong
and he just continues to make play so I
got a lot of respect for the guys we're
playing this week man Josh like you know
I appreciate you man
um it's all love all respect man I know
we uh do we got some do we got some fan
questions after this no not that one
ranch or blue cheese and I can answer
this one for you like of course it's
blue cheese people look at you different
like here if you if you ask for ranks
like and honestly I wasn't even like a
big blue cheese guy job or like it just
tastes different here in Buffalo people
don't understand that either like it's
like it's all homemade here like and
they do it right like and when you're
dipping your wings in it like it's it's
different what we got another one this
is from Bill's fan21 Josh have you ever
played defense and Von have you ever
played offense yeah so Middle School up
until seventh grade all the way through
seventh grade I played Safety too I
started off as running back
um I was juking guys out and I was like
getting hit all the time I was like I
don't want to do this like I want to
play quarterback so throughout practice
I would like grab a ball and I'd always
make sure I threw it back after a drill
and finally the coach one day it's like
you get a nice arm you don't play
quarterback you don't play quarterback
and I was like
yeah I would I would I would enjoy that
so
um
started playing quarterback uh
Pee-Wee Year my second year
um in Pee-wee's but I played Safety up
until my seventh grade year
um and then my coach was like you know
what you might be playing this game for
a while
no more no more defense just quarterback
you know the crazy thing is right I know
you might laugh at this my very first
position was quarterback really I always
thought like I was gonna be a
quarterback and even now you might see
me at practice like go through like my
drops I've seen it I'm gonna Center like
you know get a fake hand off and I you
know I do an overhand passed sidearm
pass like I just feel like I still got
like that that quarterback in my heart
and our game is it's a quarterback it's
like a quarterback League like and
playing quarterback is really one of the
most prestigious precisions in all the
sports like so I've always wanted to be
a quarterback you know it didn't happen
my way in my mind and in my heart like I
feel like I'm a quarterback and I feel
like I connect with quarterbacks that's
why we got like the friendship that we
have that's why I feel like I'm rushing
after quarterbacks and that's why I'm
always in the I feel like I'm always in
the right spot whether they stepping up
or dropping back I'm always there
because I like to think like a
quarterback situation of football I'm
looking at the play clock like I like to
think like offensive coordinator how are
they trying to lock up all those play
clubs how are they trying to how they
trying to block us like I always look at
it for my offensive mindset so my very
first position was quarterback I think
that helps you though it does it does I
like it a lot and you know I got a son
now like I want him to play quarterback
I'm not going to force him I'm not gonna
be like you know what's his Uncle Rico
from yeah from Napoleon I'm not going
forward yeah golf clubs yet he has golf
clubs he has these little toy golf clubs
you know I want him to play golf I
wanted to be a quarterback but I'm not
going to force anything I'm just going
to step out the way and let him do his
thing
um I got one last question from Abby
Harlow
how do we get to the Super Bowl this
season you know I've been on like I've
been on two Super Bowl teams before
right and I've been on some good ones
before in 2012 I feel like that was the
best team that I had with the Denver
Broncos of course we won in 2015 but the
most talented team that we had was in
2012 ended up being a Mile High Miracle
and then division around in the playoffs
and we lost that game there's so many
things that can happen right and I think
that
like me being like the experienced guy
because this is what they that's what
they brought me in to be is like they
talk about Super Bowl and really put
that energy on my gosh like and Coach
McDermott he says it perfectly like
oh you start thinking about Super Bowl
and the other games down the road like
it's like drinking from a fire hydrant
yeah it's just so much information
there's just so much to think about it's
so much expectation like to get there
the teams that I've been on how we got
there is exactly what we're doing now
like taking it one week at a time you
know being in the dogs like each and
every week in 2000 in 2015 we won nine
games within three points or less so
that game that we had like with the
Baltimore Ravens and and the game that
we had with the Miami Dolphins it was
like that for nine games of that season
so when we got to the playoffs it it was
a dog fight it's not how you win them
it's if you win yeah you got to win them
you know we played the Pittsburgh
Steelers and they were running like in a
division one in 2015 and we're driving
down the field they're getting ready to
kick a field goal to win it all of a
sudden Bradley Roby like punches the
ball out we get the ball we go down kick
a field going we win like it's those
type of plays it's been in those type of
environments all of that stuff has to
happen for us to be able to win it so
even though we have these high
expectations I think exactly where we're
doing now taking it one week at a time
taking these small cups to drink out of
that's that's really how we get there
yeah yeah I agree and to win the lottery
you gotta you gotta buy ticket our
ticket to win this Lottery you got to
make the playoffs like that's and again
that's that happens by taking it week by
week and Coach McDermott preaches
playoff caliber like that's that's our
mindset every time we step up in the
building man Josh man I love you man I
appreciate you for coming on Chromecast
that's how I love and respect man I see
you at work tomorrow oh my god let's do
it and that is the second episode of uh
Von Miller's voncast appreciate you guys
for tuning in go bills